dembele is an ancient haitian deity he
is one of the law the spirits observed
in the african religion known as haitian
voodoo in voodoo dembele is a great
white serpent deity associated with
water some versions of the religion
believe that dambella was the primordial
creator of life while others believed
that he was the first creation of god
that dembele shed his skin to create
water and thus generate life throughout
the earth in the chucky franchise
dembele is tied to water in a slightly
different way whenever the deity is
called upon he manifests himself in the
form of storm clouds and usually takes
action as a great strike of lightning
both the haitian voodoo and child's play
version seem to have a say in all things
concerning life death and overall a
whole lot of power give me the power i
beg of you
to learn how the infamous american
criminal charles lee ray got mixed up
with his eternal haitian deity stick
around to the end of this video
[Music]
a day do we susan bella give me the
views i beg of you
welcome to horror history in today's
lesson we're looking beyond the evil of
a man driven to beat death to continue
his crime career to the ancient misused
power that enabled him the voodoo lore
aspect of the child's play franchise is
mostly not expanded on in the movies in
fact series creator don mancini
acknowledges that he never even planned
to include it it was actually added by
the director and other screenwriters in
his 2017 interview with slash film he
admits that he didn't create the voodoo
stuff he didn't really like it but he
acknowledges that it's a useful plot
device that resonated with audiences it
seems that's why he uses it in a comedic
fashion later on in the franchise and
probably the answer for why the heart of
dembele is such a poorly implemented
retcon we'll get to that but first we've
got to get to the origins of dembele
from my observations for your education
i've got to take it back to the creation
of the haitian nation
according to the sacred arts of haitian
voodoo the religion is a blend of even
more ancient religions brought to the
island nation of haiti in the slave
trade that occurred starting in the
1500s this caused those religions to
blend with european religions practiced
by slave merchants and the culture
started to spread out from the western
half of this caribbean island the word
voodoo means spirit in fang a language
used in western africa historians have
theorized that their religion resonated
with slaves because they felt powerless
in their situation and these spirits
seemed to offer them an ancient power we
see a similar scenario play out in
child's play where charles lee ray is
dying and he seeks out dembele's power
in a moment of desperation but we'll get
to that if you're like me when you think
of voodoo there are a few things that
come to mind the diablo swing orchestra
song the third level on sly cooper
voodoo donuts voodoo dolls and some of
the earliest zombie movies it's not
difficult to see that pop culture is
partially responsible for the western
idea that voodoo is rooted in evil when
that's not necessarily the case for
example take voodoo dolls believers
could attempt to use them for medicinal
purposes to drive energy to one part of
the body for healing or as a token to
help communicate with past family
members but we all know the other side
of voodoo dolls they're believed to act
as an effigy or a sculptural
representation of a real person and are
often seen being pricked or stabbed with
needles in order to bring pain to that
person or worse
so long john items like voodoo dolls are
called puen they're essentially items
crafted with components that appeal to
the law the voodoo spirits that i
mentioned earlier and dambella is one of
if not the most prominent of these
spirits it stands to reason that
dambella operates under the same
neutrality that a voodoo doll does when
put into the hands of someone good
they'll attempt to use it for
communication and healing but put the
power into the hands of an evil doer and
that person may use it for revenge
destruction or completely destroying the
reputation of a toy company desecrating
a military academy and driving an entire
middle school to near insanity voodoo
worshipers pay their respects to
dumbella in a serpent temple in benin
west africa one of the countries that
haitian voodoo is said to have derived
from unlike depictions of serpents in
major western religions dembele is often
depicted standing upright separating it
from the negative snakey depictions in
judaism christianity and harry potter
during slavery the haitians were not
allowed to practice their religion due
to growing fears of their power from
slave owners according to a voodoo
exploration on ancient mysteries they
instead honored the image of saint
patrick of ireland like the guy that has
his own day named after him because he
was supposedly responsible for helping
banish snakes from ireland not sure what
the story is there but it sounds like
the slaves had the same strategy as lexi
in the chucky series if they got caught
they could just say that they were
trying to do the right thing i want you
to take the page down right now to mrs
fairchild i've already raised 75
in real life dembele is viewed as a
bestower of health prosperity and
fertility and in a small way the chucky
version of dumbella holds true to that
giving several characters a second
chance at life by granting their wish to
inhabit a new body and even at one point
helping initiate a voodoo pregnancy i
don't think i could take nine months of
this [ __ ]
silly chucky it's a voodoo pregnancy
it's accelerated
in a sense dembele touches on another
common voodoo trope zombies it's weird
to think of chucky as a zombie because
most modern zombies are tied to some
kind of disease radiation experiment or
cranberry song but the word zombie
actually derives from the haitian french
word zombie meaning a dead person
reanimated through voodoo what happens
to chucky is very similar only instead
of a body coming back to life at the
command of a voodoo spell it's a toy
coming to life for the first time and
then that toy is brought back again and
again and again and so on in the early
days of the united states dembele and
the voodoo religion did make it over to
america once again unfortunately
traveling overseas by the way of
transport of enslaved africans louisiana
would become the centerpiece for voodoo
in the u.s and dembele was mostly
worshiped by those of african descent
who over time spread out to other areas
of the country things would change in
the 1980s when one voodoo devotee spread
word of dembele's power to an outsider
[Music]
one of the voodoo families was the
bishop family i'm assuming they were one
of the most proficient in the use of
voodoo magic and contacting the law they
distanced themselves from new orleans
and ended up in chicago illinois one day
john ilsot bishop was approached by a
man named charles lee ray who was
interested in learning about the power
to be death and jon taught him the ways
of dembele not knowing that charles
would be using his teachings for evil
chucky completely devotes himself to
dumbella repainting his apartments to
murals worshiping the great serpent
deity with text that reads oh thank you
mighty dembele for life after death he
also collects a variety of voodoo
artifacts it's likely that jon also
taught charles about a magical amulet
called the heart of dambella it seems
the heart gives its wearer enhanced
capabilities and it's likely that chucky
stole it from jon and started wearing it
whenever he went on a dangerous crime
spree in case he sustained a
life-threatening injury we were first
introduced to dembele in the early
morning on november 9 1988 the same day
as charles lee ray's death at least in
his original body charles is badly
injured in a gunfight with police and
wanders into a toy store to find a
subject for his ritual unable to he
decides to try using it on a good guy
doll
[Music]
give me the power i beg of you
dark storm clouds roll into the
neighborhood at an alarming rate and a
thunderstorm suddenly begins as charles
finishes the chant lightning strikes the
top of the building shattering the glass
and creating an explosive amount of
energy sending a police officer and many
toys flying through the front windows
the power of dembele has allowed charles
to transfer his soul into the doll but
there is a caveat chucky will slowly
turn human over the next 48 hours and if
time expires he will be unable to
transfer back into a human body during
this incarnation the more time you spend
in that body more human you become
the next day chucky demands that john
help him get out of the doll's body and
abuses jon's own personal voodoo doll to
try to coerce him eventually learning he
must perform the dembele chant again to
transfer his soul into the first human
being he revealed his true self to not
staying true to his word he finishes off
jon using the doll anyways he calls on
dan bella again on november 11th to try
to transfer his soul into the body of
six-year-old andy barclay the storm
clouds appear as they had before and
bolts of lightning come down to signify
dembele offering his power but andy's
mom interrupts the ritual before it's
completed so the soul transfer never
takes place chucky is reconstructed in
october of 1990. once he is fully
reassembled we see dembele's power
activate once again in the powerful
lightning bolts that seem to come out
from within chucky it seems that by
transferring his soul into the doll
dembele would allow him to possess the
doll and have life again whenever the
doll is reformed chucky catches up with
andy and tries to perform the soul
transfer ritual again but this time is
interrupted even earlier in the process
he tries again two days later and this
time he's able to complete the chant on
andy for the first time but the soul
transfer still does not occur and
dembele's storm clouds roll back after
the failed attempt chucky's first
inclination is that he was too late
since his heart had turned human before
completing the ritual he was no longer
able to do it however it's unclear at
this stage if that was the reason or if
it was because he no longer had the
heart of dunbello with him i'll answer
that a little bit later his next attempt
is in spring of 1999 when he's
reincarnated again and tries to transfer
his soul into a new target this time a
military school student named ronald
tyler this time he succeeds in summoning
the storm clouds but again cannot
complete the chance due to an
interruption by two superior officers
who confiscate the doll he eventually
does catch up with tyler inside of the
coolest carnival dark ride ever
[Music]
this time he's unable to complete the
chance because andy shoots him though he
does get really close i'm guessing that
dembele was itching for action at this
point and was probably disappointed that
he didn't get to do his thing however he
would get back into the swing of things
not long after that when chucky's
ex-girlfriend tiffany valentine
reassembled the doll and placed it on a
pentagram in her trailer apparently
trying to mix haitian voodoo with
satanism i guess merely reassembling the
doll again no longer worked possibly
because it wasn't a perfect recreation
so she calls upon dembele's power to
help her out using a book called voodoo
for dummies she finds a new spell
capable of bringing chucky back to life
it doesn't appear to be effective at
first awake
awake
awake
but chucky does regain consciousness
that evening the next day he
electrocutes tiffany but in order to
salvage her calls on dembele again to
transfer her soul from her human body
into the body of this doll she
desperately searches for another spell
to revert her back to a human body and
chucky informs her that the only way to
do that is with the amulet known as the
heart of dumbella this brings up the
question why did chucky ever attempt to
transfer into a human body before
without first retrieving the amulets is
this what prevented him from being
successful with andy or was it actually
because he was too late and had already
turned part human the closest i can get
to answering that question is the slash
film article that i referenced earlier
don mancini addresses the issue when the
interviewer asks why chucky suddenly
needs to have the amulet four movies
into the franchise hey that contradicts
what chucky's been trying to do in the
first three movies but my feeling was no
maybe that's why he was unsuccessful in
the first three movies he wasn't using
the heart of dembele he was a student of
voodoo so i went with the logic that he
was constantly learning about this very
complicated mythology obviously this is
just a quote in an interview not
necessarily canon but it's the closest
thing we're ever going to get to an
answer so i'll roll with that to this
point dembele's power is mostly used
unsuccessfully for soul transfer rituals
with the occasional awakening ritual
thrown in but things were about to get
more complicated and we would see the
true scope of dembele's power for the
first time
[Music]
after retrieving the amulets chucky
makes yet another attempt to perform
dembele's soul transfer ritual this time
his wife tiffany is the one to foil him
by stabbing him in the back kind of a
tease from dembele's point of view
chucky and tiffany are both dead in a
matter of minutes but with one last
ounce of her life tiffany gives birth to
their child glenn glenn is found in the
cemetery with the heart of dembele and
holds onto it not knowing the truth
behind its power until five years later
in march of 2004 when he finds his
parents who have now been relegated to
inanimate movie props he reads the
inscription on the back of it which
happens to be the same awakened spell
that tiffany used to bring back chucky
in 99
as usual the result is an overload of
electricity but the spell is successful
in bringing both dolls back to life
which later results in chucky trying to
transfer all three of their souls into
human bodies this time with the heart of
dumbella enhanced to aid him this eighth
attempt is of course unsuccessful but
this time chucky himself is the one to
stop it
this is nuts and i have a very high
tolerance for nuts if this is what it
takes to be human then i would rather
take my chances as a supernaturally
possessed doll it's less complicated
chucky decides he'd rather remain in
doll form because he feels that version
of himself is a more infamous killer
than his human form charles lee ray as i
discussed earlier dembele has and always
will be impartial to good versus evil
and allows chuckie to go on living as a
doll most likely forever however that
does not spell the end of dembele's
involvement because tiffany still wants
a human body for her and her child she
knocks out hollywood actress jennifer
tilly and performs the chant on her it
takes a few moments but after completing
the ritual she has successfully switched
into the human body just in time too
nobody leaves me tiffany takes the
amulet and uses it to transfer glenn's
soul into one of a pair of human twins
or possibly both twins it's never
explicitly explained how that all went
down either glenn is able to possess
both human bodies at once or he or she
is switching back and forth between the
two whenever he or she pleases many
years go by before chucky attempts to
contact dembele again he does so on
april 8 2013 with alice pierce the
granddaughter of one of his love
interests from 25 years ago
give me the power i beg of you we don't
actually know if he was successful with
this though but according to chuckie
himself he is able to transfer his own
soul back into a human body with the
help of a brand new voodoo spell that he
discovered on the internet
that allows him to transfer his soul
into more than one body at a time
a few years ago i came across this
groovy new spell on
voodoofordummies.com that changed
everything
now i can be me and me and me and
theoretically anyone or anything with
two legs and a hand for stabbing
like alice he takes advantage of this by
transferring himself into two duplicate
good guy dolls so now he's inhabiting
three bodies thanks to dunbella one of
them is most likely killed and the other
is captured if you want to know more
about that you gotta watch my andy
barkley horror history actually there's
three of us at the moment and the cult
is growing all the time in january 2017
the remaining one free chucky doll goes
to herogate psychiatric hospital where
he encounters two more good guy dolls
and expands his cult out into that one
interesting note about this new dembele
spell is that after the transfer the
chuckies appear to operate independently
that is they aren't a hive mind if you
share information with just one of them
the others aren't necessarily going to
know that information one of the three
chuckies at the asylum has one more task
for his voodoo overlord though roll it
[Music]
give me all the power i think of you
he uses the spell on the 29 year old
paraplegic woman in nica piers and it's
here that we see one more interesting
side effect of the power of voodoo for
the first time since she was born nika
is able to walk her legs are functional
with charles lee ray's soul taking over
her body when you think about it this
makes a lot of sense non-disabled people
are able to stand up and walk because of
the muscles in our legs exerting force a
good guy doll has no muscles but chucky
has always been able to walk while
inhabiting them that means that it's
dembele's magic that's moving them
nika's legs don't work but it's okay
because they are also moved thanks to
the might of dembele there is one more
dembele intervention that we know of
which is tiffany using the
voodoofordummies.com curse to split her
soul back into the female doll we don't
exactly know when this happens but it's
most likely the last one chronologically
with chucky back again in the 20s it's
likely that dambella will strike again
in the near future i think this is the
perfect place to end this lesson on
dembele if you like what you saw check
that playlist on the left where i
analyze the histories of other chucky
franchise characters i've also covered
deities and spirits from other
franchises such as the conjuring
franchise the world of stephen king and
others so if that interests you make
sure you subscribe to cz's world for new
horrors every week ring the death bell
for all notifications and i'll see you
in the next one assuming we both survive